Professor LS yes and a f ah nice to meet
you and you good
luck Dr frud sit please not there that's
the transformation couch you'd be
careful why would you come here to see
me if you disagree so passionately with
My Views you've insisted all your life
that the very concept of God is
ludicrous yes clash between God Satan ah
but I did not say whose side I was on I
consider what people tell me far less
interesting than what they choose not to
tell me have you frightened off your
professor yet not yet soon
perhaps you challenge my disbelief is
that great I do well done good too late
to turn back
now seems me Professor you never matured
enough to face the terror of being alone
in the dark
what is it you think I'm so yeah we're
all
terrified do you bury your doubts you
bury your members of the war but at the
core of your
being we're all cowards before
death